the three muslims
how's it going bro
alhamdulillah how are you guys
good bro
glad to finally have you here before we
jump right in man tell us the back story
behind your name was bro were there two
mods growing up and you were the one on
dean or what
that's a good question i actually um
when i first like hopped on social media
hopped on tick tock
it was i kind of just fell into like the
dowel content so it's actually more dawa
at first
and then i just realized that i don't
necessarily want to do like specifically
that would content so i switched it up a
bit
i tried thinking of different things and
helen why it kind of just stuck
but i'm
it's funny that you mentioned that
because i'm actually trying to i'm
thinking of switching up the username
again
i want to make i don't know i kind of i
kind of wanted to make it my eye but
obviously that's already taken
yeah bro if only if only subhanallah
but for those of you
that are in the viewers that are
probably wondering who this brother is
masha allah mois why don't you tell them
a little bit about your journey
yeah man um
so i'm 20 years old just graduated
college
um i've always a panel i've always
kind of had like like a thing for making
videos and whatnot and just
kind of pushing people towards dean and
i would post actually youtube videos a
while ago but it was it was small it was
like a couple you know 100 subscribers
maybe a couple of views per video and
then my friends kept pushing one friend
in particular kept pushing tick tock
he's like bro you need to make a tick
tock you need to make a tick tock and i
had this mentality back then like well i
i thought tik tok was
like the tool of the shaitan like that
was my mindset i was like nothing good
comes out of this app you know it's just
all fitnah right and so i stayed away
from longest time
eventually kind of got to me he actually
he had a tick tock and he had me um
make a video on there we were on the
beach
and
i just did this dawah video like there's
just something about the day of judgment
or whatever
and it blew up it did really well and
all the comments were like what's this
guy's tick tock what does he have to
take out blah blah blah and he's like
see like like i don't know i think he
was just seeing that kind of support and
the fact that like yo like i'm already
making videos but there's so much more
engagement on here and the people like
you know they like the content so from
there um i made the account and
like i said it was just kind of like
primarily darwin in the beginning
um and then i kind of just varied it up
a bit i kind of always
you know sometimes
i've always kind of like wanted to make
beneficial content but
i swayed a little bit from specifically
dawa so instead of like
um i started interpreting just more like
like how to level up how to build more
discipline how to fix your sleep
schedule like these kind of like life
lessons that can just be that's just
broader than specifically dawah
but anyways that kind of started up um
alhamdulillah the tick tock started
doing really well
and i just kind of moved that over to
instagram and then youtube and it's been
a journey i'm sure you guys know but
it's a lot of it's a lot of consistency
you have to stay consistent every week
you gotta pump it out and especially
with school and whatnot it was um
it was difficult but also i really like
keeping myself busy so
it kind of worked out alhamdulillah and
you know i've gone this far and shall
allah you know keeps going inshallah
people find benefit from it
about it bro it seems like you just
graduated bro i saw your story the other
day masha allah but yeah i don't know if
this is something that you don't tell
the public like what you were telling us
you know backstage about what you want
to do with your career and what you're
doing with school and you briefly just
mentioned that you know with school and
everything it is about so what are you
doing right now in terms of your
education in terms of your studies you
want to tell the viewers what's going on
yeah that's fine um
inshallah i'm looking to
apply to go into dental school so that's
kind of what i want to do long term
and
it was well that was a struggle i'll
tell you for
for those first couple years of college
and even the last years of high school
probably the most stressful thing was
trying to figure out like what am i
going to do for the next 20 30 40 years
of my life like that's a question that
gets
planted on you and you kind of you're
expected to like figure all that out
right and so for me that was very
stressful
um
the one thing i tell people and i made a
youtube video about this the biggest
thing is just you have to get yourself
out there in the real world and just
experiment with as many things as
possible and see what kind of sticks you
know see what you know we always talk
about passion and whatnot
but you're not going to find your quote
unquote passion by by sitting around or
trying to like google it like that's not
how it works you have to go out there
you have to experiment you have to try
different things and so that's what i
did with career and with my hobbies so
for career i shadowed basically
everything i could right i shot on
doctors pediatricians optometrists
pharmacists dentists computer scientists
like i tried everything right and ham
the dentistry was the thing that kind of
looked good on paper and i could
actually like i enjoyed it a bit right
i'm not super passionate about teeth you
don't have to be passionate like that
passionate about it right but it was a
good career and so i thought allah and i
just chose it right
um and then with hobbies it's the same
thing bro you have to try different
things like i tried playing piano i
played soccer i freaking
i can't you know it's just a bunch of
different things and i always love
making videos you know and so i kind of
just stuck with that and alhamdulillah
and that's grown but you have to get
yourself out there bro you have to you
have to really experiment
i was going to say aside from just
putting yourself out there and trying a
bunch of different things what advice do
you have for people that still can't
find out what they want to do in terms
of a career
[Music]
in terms in terms of a career
you know that's that's a so i would say
that step one is to try things because i
feel like most people
haven't really done that
i feel like if if you actually
get out there and and try it internship
or shadow i feel like that'll give you a
real because the thing is fed right
a career might look good on paper
but
you won't actually
know and fully understand what that
career is until you immerse yourself in
it until you see it for yourself and
that's why subhanallah i see a lot of
people like for example that want to go
into med school right or want to be like
a surgeon until they they see blood
coming out of the patient for the first
time and then they realize like they're
not good with blood like you have to put
yourself out there
um
[Music]
i feel like that would be the first step
and then i feel like perspective is also
really important so this is one of this
is kind of a it i have with
what society pushes nowadays where and
you guys might disagree this is my
personal opinion but i feel like too
much emphasis is put on your passion
like you have to wake up every day and
just be ready to jump out of bed just
ready to go smile on your face and
you're super excited to get to work
bro realistically that's that's not real
like that's not life and the problem
with pushing that so much is that
like
you're not gonna find that and so you're
gonna think like oh there's no career is
right for me or oh i can't find my
passion because you're expecting this
like thing that's gonna like stimulate
you or you're to be super excited about
all the time and also like the reality
is too and i'm sure you guys can talk
about this more than i can but let's say
you take
your passion right
um or this hobby that you have let's say
it's photography and you want to make
that your career well now instead of it
being like a hobby that you were doing
on the side in your free time now it's
something that like you have to make
money off of in order to provide for
your family so there's that added like
level of stress now because it's like
now it's not something like i'm just
doing for fun it's something like i have
to make this work if i want to survive
and if i want to provide you know what i
mean
so i'm not saying i'm definitely
definitely not preaching to pick a
career that you can't stand to that
something that you hate going into work
for you know that's probably why that's
probably the worst scenario that you can
because you're spending eight hours a
day that's that's
almost half the time that you're awake
you know doing something that you don't
enjoy
but what i would say is get that per get
that mentality out of your head of i
have to like be super passionate about
this thing that i do and try to pick
something that's that's that's um
logical
something that you can see yourself
doing something that will give you
financial stability
and um
that you don't you know you don't hate
waking up every morning and doing
and also there's a concept as well as
just
you know like
we can plan as much as we want but we
have no idea where we're gonna be in 10
years five years one year we don't right
so you plan to the best of your ability
and once you've really exerted that from
yourself and there's nothing else that
you can do you have to leave it on allah
but yeah
well it reminds me of uh this
conversation that i have with this
person that's close to me
and they're looking for a job right now
and they were telling me how
how depressed they were because
the job that they're looking for the
specific type of thing that they're
looking for it's just not coming up
and i was like well you you do realize
like you're limiting yourself by only
looking for this like one little thing
and then they also went to add on that
like
they want passion they want to wake up
and feel like excited and like they
like they actually want to do what
they're doing i'm like listen
like that's
that's delusional to things like that
like
the passion
you could be passionate about one thing
right now and then
you wake up the next morning and that
same passion isn't there anymore bro
like bro i hate to put it like this but
you could be passionate about
uh the girl you're about to marry and
then like at some point down the line
you ain't you're not gonna be as
passionate as you once would
you know so it's like but that's the
thing about passion
it comes and it goes it comes and it
goes it's like a wave
there's a peaks there's the lows there's
a peaks at the low so it's like you
can't get caught up on like oh i need to
have this passion because then you're
just going to be chasing the high
but you're never going to get the high
hmm that's you're 100 right and that's
actually like because i um
i told you guys that you know like in
the beginning i was kind of chasing that
passion right like i wanted to really
find something that
i really liked right and alhamdulillah
i'm glad that my parents kind of opened
my eyes to it a bit because when you're
young you don't when you're young it's
just you right you don't have to take
care of anyone you just have to take
care of yourself
so you almost have this like selfish
perspective of it if it's like what do i
want but you gotta realize that five ten
years down the line you have a family
well that you need to provide for so you
have to take that into account as well
when
when when deciding what career you wanna
you wanna choose
bro especially that's double if you if
you're trying to do dollop bro if you're
trying to do dawah because you look at
the imams back then a lot of them didn't
just rely on the dawah for money or
provisioning they always had some type
of like skill or trade or something that
they were doing and the reason they did
that is they detached the tawa from
their source of income and i see too
many people i'm not going to mention any
of these may allah bless them all but
when they rely on the dawah for the
money then they're going to do whatever
and say whatever just to get that income
and a lot of them they it gets the the
message you know kind of lost in the
sauce or corrupted and and they're
saying a lot of things that are on
islamic just so just because they know
you know it'll fit societal needs and
quota and get their income
um i worked a few jobs in my life you
know i'm only 21. i i've actually worked
a few jobs
and if
probably remember very well a few months
ago when i was working at a car wash
nine hours a day
and um
honestly one of the best jobs i've ever
had
was my first one
and that was because
it was just a job at superstore stocking
shelves and talking to people whatever
it was because the environment is
because the people there the people
around me
you know i was excited to go and see who
i'm gonna be working with today you know
they usually book two people for the
night
and
that atmosphere that
friendship that environment those peers
and co-workers they really made
the job site let's say jobs it was a
superstore they really made it fun
um i work gardening which is nice to be
in nature but it's just
it was wasn't enjoyable i tried to be an
apprentice electrician once and it just
i didn't find it to be super enjoyable
and the job that i'm working now i'm not
talking about you know fight and
although i love it here for the same
reasons um the job i'm working now is
amazing because the environment the
people there like you're not always
going to be motivated yourself right but
if you're around people who know how to
motivate how know how to encourage you
know how to help you grow as a person
that is amazing that's why people
encourage you know study groups in
university in college and to put
yourself in a good environment with good
people
the same work for the job site like if
you walk in
as a doctor
um with the most amazing team
with you then you're going to enjoy a
lot more than if you walk in as a doctor
with a bunch of
old
nagging and annoyed and annoying people
who
don't want to take care of other
patients you know what i mean
yeah so
your favorite job is the first one
it's it's kind of hard to say because i
really love this job that i'm working
now so i guess the one that would take
the top
place would be the job i'm working on
alhamdulillah especially
muslims
but that would that's definitely one i'm
not going to forget that first job i was
about to say like oh man you should quit
what you're doing now and just go back
to the
store bro that's your that's your
purpose
that's a logic bro that's the logic of
some people though yeah yeah everyone i
used to work with there is khan now so i
don't think it'd be as enjoyable
bro one other topic that i wanted to
dive right into with uh with brother
moaz was
the the struggles of being just a muslim
you know growing up in the west
you know a lot of there's a dichotomy i
hear people saying okay there's a lot of
fitnah here you know i wish i grew up
you know in the haram or you know
somewhere in the middle east in a muslim
country quote unquote that even exists
and i have a lot of other people saying
okay cool
yes but there's different fitness you
know growing up in the middle east you
know compared to here here it's like you
know allah is gonna worry better you
know here we can do tawa here there's
more opportunity so for you are you are
you kind of on the side like which side
would you have to pick if if you know it
was up to you and you wanted to move
would you make hijra would you stay here
i i used to be on that side i used to be
on that boat where it's like i wish i
lived in the time of the prophet
medina or like i wish i lived in qatar
right now or whatever
but the more and more stories you hear i
feel like you realize that
no matter where you go bro there's gonna
be fitnah no matter where you go
especially nowadays with like the
internet and whatnot like that's global
right that fitna is always going to be
there
and
subhanallah bro like the thing that we
don't also realize is that
the fact that it's easier for them
means that it's going they're going to
be
asked more about it right for example
like i remember back in our home in
egypt the masjid is literally a two
minute walk two minute walk the nearest
measured here for us is a ten minute
drive so if i live
back home i'm gonna be asked on the day
of judgement like your measured was two
minutes away why didn't you go for salah
right because it was easier for you
and you also have to realize as well
that
sometimes i feel like especially in
these muslim countries you take you take
your islam for granted like you don't
value it as much
as when
you've grown up around the fitna and you
still decide not to and i had friends
well i one one in particular comes to
mind who i remember in high school you
know he
he was not on the dean at all you know
subhanallah sometimes like like i didn't
at one point like i forgot he was muslim
like not to i just i didn't i didn't
know you know what i mean like he was he
was off
and subhanallah like he hits me up
you know a year after we graduate he's
like yo are they still doing juma i like
our local message i was like of course
come through
and i'd start seeing him every jummah
and then i start seeing him like for
aisha right
and then so we just started talking
about it and talking and and he told me
he was like
all these
all the mess that he got into with with
the fitna that you have in the west
nowadays and how accessible it is and
how just submerged he got into it i'm
talking
like the music the rap he was making
music
um
getting into gangs and that kind of
stuff
and
one thing or not like
something happened and it kind of just
clicked with him right and ever since
then he's been he's been on his deen you
know what i mean but i feel like
that that's a lot stronger if you live
in the west and you've been around the
fitness then if you kind of just grew up
and everyone around you is muslim and
whatnot and i've seen bro i've been back
home in egypt and
you know
like it's it's unfortunate but
sometimes there's there's more fitna
going on there than there is here you
know
this this this illusion that like ah man
like like back home is just beautiful
and perfect and everyone's sending
salawah 24 7.
it doesn't happen you know unfortunately
the fitness is just everywhere so you
have to realize like you just have to
you know realize that allah puts you
where you are and just start asking
yourself what can you do with this what
can you do with this bro
the fact that you're around like
non-muslims all the time
is an insane opportunity for dawah are
you kidding me like if you get one of
them to convert bro every single deed
that they do for the rest of their lives
you're getting reward for that people
back home where everyone around you is
muslim they don't have the opportunity
right so it's all about perspective how
can i get good deeds how can i use what
allah has given me right now you know to
to just make the most out of my
situation
hmm
well that's
that's deep
my teacher
i remember my teacher telling us that
you know a lot of people are like oh i
wish i was alive at the time of the
process
basically they wish they weren't in this
current situation but
the problem is they don't know if they
would have been in abu bakr or in abuja
at the time of the prophet
like we don't know if we would have been
these you know super practicing muslims
people who you know like the brother
said would have walked to the masjid and
every day and so on and so forth you
could have been like abuja
you could have been one of the people
that rejected the message because it was
more difficult to accept it um you know
due to the pressures and having to stay
up all night in prayer in the beginning
of islam and so on and so forth these
were unfortunately reasons where why
people didn't really practice to stand
back
well
it makes me think man because
for the longest time i always had this
uh
idealistic way of seeing
uh the environment that of which i was
in and that i wanted to be in
and i would always say to myself all
that i want to live in like the best
environment like a tropical environment
beautiful
and then bro
allah allowed me to do that
allah allowed me to go and live
in the tropics in thailand
and wallahi was beautiful it was so
beautiful but you know what happens
you get used to it
you get used to it and then it no longer
has the same effect so then it's like
after that now my mind is gearing up for
like the next place okay what's the
better place for me to live in and like
i'm thinking about all these different
places i'm thinking um abu dhabi i'm
thinking
saudi arabia i'm thinking egypt i'm
thinking algeria i'm thinking morocco
i'm thinking costa rica i'm thinking bro
i'm thinking my home country portugal
i'm thinking all these things
and i'm like well it's just going to end
up in the same thing
and then i'm thinking oh well i want a
place where there's all muslims and then
it's like the same realization you had
is what came to me as well where it's
like
you know whether you're in a place
where there's not many muslims or you're
in a place where there are many muslims
like
there's still going to be fitnah
there's still going to be problems it's
not going to be perfect this is the
dunya like it's always going to be like
this
and then like the the bigger realization
that i had was um
you should be like you said
whatever allah is putting you and if if
where you are right now you're finding
that you can't leave that that's like
where you are well that's exactly where
you're meant to be and that's where
you're supposed to do
uh the best work that you can possibly
do that allah put you here on this earth
for
it reminds me of the ayah allah
is vast it's wide so worship me right
wherever you are you can worship allah
wherever you are you don't have to be in
mecca or saudi or whatever
to get that you know subhanallah even it
reminds me like one of my best ramadans
was actually quarantined in ramadan
right 2020 when we were at home
it wasn't you know like
you you'd think that like oh you're
being deprived from the measured and the
social interactions and whatnot but
subhanallah there's so many different
forms of worship there's everything can
be worshipped right and so you can use
any opportunity um
that you get and also on that note as
you guys are the phrase or the saying
less is more right
i realized that bro with um
[Music]
ah subhanallah what were we talking
about
i forget where i was going with that
when you're talking about like the
being exactly where you are
that like you can do your best work that
right where you wanted to like you
wanted to move because you got used to
it and what not like us as humans like
we're kind of naturally instinctively
right
allah goes on he says like it was made
beautiful for the man like the love of
of women and gold and this and like he
keeps going like
we're kind of almost made to to always
want more and that's one of that's one
of the things that you have to really
have jihad on to be content with with
what you have and you will learn quickly
on that like wallahi like
some of my happiest times or some of my
most just times where i was most at
peace were just the simpler times you
know it's not when like the social
medias were popping off and this and
that no it's the times where like i was
just secluded in my room reading quran
you know or i just had a deep talk with
a friend it's just those simple
just times that don't really need much
you find those a lot of times have the
most value
for real bro
there's so much that i want to say right
now but it's so personal and we're live
so i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna keep it low-key
i love going back backstage but uh mars
bro what are you what are your thoughts
on marriage right now you know you're
young you know the sun is obviously to
get married as young as possible you
know if you have the ability but you
know living in the west bro is is tough
man it's tough because because this
there's the whole financial thing you
know it's our responsibility as men
you don't understand bro like this is
like the number one topic that guys talk
about all the time like i'm saturated
with marriage conversations
understand that that the
the
the thing about you know the fitnah and
whatnot and you want to get married
young and it is
can get married so let them get married
right friends haram for sure
i feel like
what isn't emphasized enough is actually
like
being someone who is ready for marriage
and i know it sounds really just kind of
like
bland but
like bro you have to be a man
that's able to at least take care of
himself before you even think about
taking care of someone else i feel like
people don't understand how big of a
responsibility marriage really is you
know especially with you see this
tsunami i'm sure you can relate
but like with tick tock and everything
like this whole
concept of marriage is talked about as
if it's just like
as if it's just a game or as if it's
just kind of like something that happens
and it's one and done bro marriage is a
lifetime commitment i'm talking until
the day you die bro
like are you really going to make a
decision that big
like off of a whim or a desire you feel
me
and then you have to realize especially
as a man bro and i talk to my like i
talk about this all the time with the
guys where it's like
you have to realize that like
it
it it's not just like
man subhanallah i'm well i'm saturated
we've been talking about this like all
weekend
but it's um
with marriage particularly it's it's not
it's not something that you can just
kind of like
you have to give it some thought and you
have to really build yourself up as a
person first before you take that
decision and one of my best friends he
he's married and he got married young so
he's been married for about a year and a
half
and he got married when he was 20. right
so same age as me
but the thing is with him is that he
knew from like the age of 15 16 that he
wanted to get married and he wanted to
build a family and he was very very
mature for his age so he was ready and
he understood that commitment and i
actually made a q a with him on my on my
youtube channel where he we go through
kind of like all these questions and
whatnot and he mentions how he like he
realizes that marriage from the
beginning he realized that it was a
responsibility right it wasn't something
that you're playing around with and that
um
it's a lifetime commitment but at the
same time
it's an opportunity for so much
right you're providing for someone
you're you're feeding someone you're
clothing someone you're every time you
pray now you pray with someone else you
get the reward for jamaa right he has a
beautiful outlook on it
but i feel like
as much as it's emphasized that like oh
like wait till you're
wait till you're like a little older to
get married oh you have to have a job
first you have to
no i feel like maybe that's
overemphasized a little too much but
what really really isn't talked about is
you have to build yourself up as a man
really like you have to build yourself
up before you take on something like
marriage
yeah yeah i feel like
my bed
mommy go ahead
oh no i was just gonna like
say there's like another side of that
coin
where it's like
the moment that you do
get married
the responsibility like forces you
to become a man
i think that's why it was like so
recommended and on top of that that you
know when you get married it completes
your theme
and all that good stuff alhamdulillah
but it's more so the fact of like
if you if you're married
you not have to support this other
person along as with yourself
and then if if they're pregnant well now
you got another
living thing that you're gonna have to
support
so it's like you quickly get to the
point where it's like you have to snap
out of that childish state and say like
all right i i gotta say bismillah and
just take care of business here
in whatever way is necessary of course
you know but
i understand where you're coming from
i understand like there should be like
some some level in your mind of like
okay i feel like i'm ready you know i
feel like i want this that's that's what
should be there but to say like i'm 100
ready i don't think anyone will ever be
100 ready bro i'm not
it's kind of like um
a lot of brothers they say
oh i'm not making enough money to
support a wife yet it's like that's fair
right that's fair because you know you
you want to be real you don't want to
like get a wife not have enough money
for her but then it's like allah says
like
which i don't remember exactly what he
said so i'm going to butcher it
um forgive me for this
but
you can't expect to
provide everything yourself like who's
providing for you are you providing for
yourself or is it allah that's providing
for you
it's a lot is providing for you so
at the end of the day like
you have to have trust in allah it's
kind of like the the story where
um you had the arabs and they were
burying their
daughters
or
killing killing their kids or something
like that because they didn't think they
would be able to support them
or something like that i don't know i'm
butchering it forgive me
but it you guys get the point you guys
get the point yeah
basically do not kill your children out
of fear of poverty something something
along those lines so yeah
and um yes marriage does make a marriage
does make a man um not because not just
because he's you know fulfilling
responsibilities and obligations but
because he knows he has to and that he's
practicing these things now it does
build discipline and and that's you know
manhood essentially but only when a man
knows he has to do it or a man cares
enough to have to do it because there's
unfortunately a lot of guys that get
into a relationship and
they'll have one part down which is like
the protection of their wife and then
protecting their wife is like you know
you don't leave the room you sit here
and you just
cooking clean and whatever get ready to
have kids
but
yeah that's not that's not the way of a
muslim that's not how muslims are like
yes you know muslims do protect their
women sometimes by telling them stay
home 100
but not by locking them into in a cage
and you know never taking them out never
doing anything with them unfortunately a
lot of people have that mentality a lot
of women have the mentality of just you
know his money's my money my money is my
money screw off you know and they have
all these weird wild concepts from the
very conception of the idea of marriage
in their head
what the brother mentioned oh you have
to be financially stable to get married
and so on and so forth but what
constitutes as being financially stable
is it you know being able to get a a
whole semi detached and two cars and uh
so on and so forth or is it having
enough to get by
because allah says in the quran if this
was a prerequisite in islam and by allah
then allah wouldn't have said in the
quran to mention he says
basically if two poor slaves were to get
married for the sake of allah would
enrich them
so allah should think if you want risk
if you want to be increased then get
married even if you're a poor slave
marrying the poor slave
of like we have people nowadays like
listen you need a bachelor's degree
if you're weak if you're strong masters
degree phd
and uh you need to make seven figures a
year and have two homes bro the cars and
you're looking like you're giving more
some cognitive dissonance bro and let's
think about we're not we're not we're
not trying to disagree with you but even
if we are it's okay because we disagree
among ourselves
all the time but the reality the truth
of the matter is
i'm a big believer and just get married
and keep moving because you're never
going to stop your your self-improvement
as a man you know it doesn't stop in
marriage and i see i see too much of the
other extreme too bro i see too many
people being like okay i want to get my
body wet i want to get my mind right get
my qualifications get that income but
then they were only doing it for a woman
and then when they finally get that
woman because they they place the woman
at that position of like you know
incentive
they kind of let their foot off the gas
when in reality it's never gonna end bro
you're gonna have kids you're gonna have
you know you're never gonna be at that
point where you're ready enough you know
so it's kind of like i'm a big advocate
especially once it's somewhere to like
get right early just bite the bullet and
it'll just build you know early on
yeah no i agree yeah
there's a standard right obviously
there's a level of readiness that you
have right but but we shouldn't we
shouldn't add to it right yeah like like
like there's a minimum but like we don't
want to go into the other extreme where
it's like paralysis by analysis you know
there's too many people like 35 you know
they're not married yet
yeah
yeah like
you okay you're on your deen you know
islam you know your rights as a man you
know your wife's rights as a woman or
vice versa if you're a man or a woman um
you know the obligations of a marriage
how to run a household you know how to
live as a human being you know how to
live with another human being uh you do
your due diligence when it comes to them
right you know what you're capable of
you know your compatibility if you are
compatible to begin with all these
things yes you have to are not get out
of the way but once you're out of the
way
they're on their danger on your dean
you're compatible with them and they're
compatible with you there's not much
more to it you have enough to get by
you're a working man you have a place to
stay even if it's like you know in a
basement or something like these are all
things where
you know it's just enough and
islamically allah will reward you for
doing it for his sake he will increase
you for doing it for his sake as soon as
you start getting into like you know i'm
not going to get married till i'm you
know 35 graduated making seven figures
it's like
okay
it's kind of like you're opening
yourself up to years
and years of fitness and tribulation and
especially if you're in university
right a bunch of people opposite gender
at the
the peak of their
sexual drive
and put in the most stressful place
you know have fun
[Music]
like i know it's an extreme example bro
to be honest but like how many people
are in that predicament where i know a
lot of sisters too they're like you know
i want to make sure i get everything
right get my career right get all this
right under like 32 33. and i know this
is something i don't say this to be
offensive but science proves this their
fertility the risks with pregnancy the
complications it's really high after 30
broke and the reality is there's so many
sisters in their 30s trying to get
married because they're like oh i had to
like you know i had to do what society
told me to do
and then get ready for marriage and then
position myself ready for marriage and
men too you know vice versa it applies
both ways
i have a question are are any of you
guys married
i'm married and romney are gonna be
married in a few weeks inshallah
actually
no way i love my vedic brothers why are
you guys asking me questions about
marriage let me ask you guys questions
okay so
so okay
so was
what was my question
was the was the um oh yeah yeah when did
you guys know
or do you ever get to a point where you
know like you're ready for marriage or
do you like you said father you just
have to kind of like bite the bullet
we planned but allah plans better bro
subhanallah had it been up to me i would
have been nowhere bro
but subhanallah i
th the older i get bro the more i
realize i try to like stop resisting the
way that the that allah is pushing in my
life you know the more i try to create
you know this this false notion that i'm
behind the steering wheel and try to be
in control of everything the more the
more anxiety and stress i get but the
more i leave it to allah the more i
realize that
just comes my way bro if i don't resist
anymore
but
the advice that i would give most men is
you never fully know if you're ready
until marriage until after you're
married girl i know it's
counterintuitive but you need to
position yourself in a way where you're
doing the fat
so to speak like rami was saying you
know the basics you know just to
position yourself ready to be married
you know you have some type of savings
you have some source of income you have
some type of direction you're on dean
and
you know regardless of how difficult it
is um you know today's climate and then
you just jump the gun you just get
married and then you see if it's if it's
meant to be no i'm not saying don't
don't vet the woman you know don't have
you know red flags that you screen her
through you know don't talk to her don't
get to know her you know at least in a
halal permissible way just for a bit but
once that's done there's there's no
point
yeah yeah very very briefly said masha
allah and i want to emphasize that point
that you mentioned in the beginning that
we don't know allah knows you know we
plan allah
because you're not going to know if
you're ready to be married or not you're
not but that's why we have this tomorrow
we have the right sort of support
i mean let me tell you a story my man i
i tried getting married when i was uh
18. right
i made i i tried i tried i tried
and it didn't work out
and such is life alhamdulillah and i'm
very happy for it and anytime a door
gets close in your face you should be
happy
you should thank allah because allah not
only is saving you from that but he's
still pointing you in the direction
you're supposed to go in and that is you
know basically what happened with me in
hundred and now in sha allah i'm getting
married soon if it doesn't work out then
it's just allah be in a another
direction
and everything you learn along the way
each time is something that you need for
when you do get married right so all
these things are very very helpful to
think about and i would say
the
best general advice i could give is
obviously firstly the advice of the
process set up be on your religion and
have good character and i would go
not the advice of the process that i'm
falling short right not in any way but
just be more specific
and clarify um a part of
you know having that good character with
your spouse i would say
firstly when it comes to them
think highly of them but don't expect
too too much
right but when it comes to yourself
don't think highly of yourself but have
high expectations for yourself a lot of
people they have the complete inverse
they think highly of themselves and they
don't have many expectations for
themselves in their relationship and
their partner sometimes they think very
little of them
or maybe even if they think a lot of
them whatever they have super high
expectations of them and when they don't
meet these amazing expectations that you
know most people are not going to meet
it's all the sudden i don't want to be
with this person anymore so on and so
forth so
i think the best general advice i can
give off that
that's beautiful
what was the question again
i was falling asleep man
no no no because um
he asked how do you know if you're ready
for marriage yeah but
it's just with romney's answer was on
kind of confusing me on like what the
question was
but he gave a beautiful answer man love
bless him i think i think romney went on
on a spin-off based on what i said so i
think that's why yeah but it was still
relevant it should be a little more
clear that's when you you know you're
ready for marriage when you can expect
highly of yourself to think lowly of
yourself and expect
decently think a decent amount of things
from them and not think lowly of them
basically
it reminds me have you guys seen that
thing where like you write down like
they tell you like write down like the
qualities and attributes that you want
in the spouse
right so you have that in mind but then
they tell you to flip it and ask
yourself if you have those same
qualities yeah right like are you
expecting something way higher of your
spouse that you don't have
it's a really good it's it goes back to
my original point where it's like before
you worry about someone else man you
have to
you have to worry about yourself and you
have to improve yourself and also i'll
much one more thing sorry on help but um
romney mentioned the
you know like we plan on allah plans and
how you try to get married multiple
times i heard this there's this
beautiful i don't know if there's a poem
or just a saying um but it was um
[Music]
so it's like i make dua to allah for my
situation
if he gives it to me then i become happy
like one time
and if he doesn't give it to me i'm
happy ten times more
uh
because the first one right was my
choice and the second one is the choice
of allah then the knower of the unknown
subhanallah so it's like if you like we
need to like bro it's crazy how if you
change your perspective
like
life could just be so much more pleasing
where it's like you really really want
this thing
but you realize again you do your part
if it doesn't work out you have to
understand that it's allah's plan and
and he knows what you don't know well he
knows what you don't know and i learned
this lesson bro
um
in these last couple weeks i'll share
this and then i'll stop talking
but um
the last couple weeks before finals were
very very stressful because
i had enough credits to graduate but i
was missing one class that i needed as a
pre-rec for dental school right so i'm
coming on my last i have this whole plan
right i was gonna take my gap year i was
gonna go study at column and whatnot and
now all of a sudden everything's halted
and i might have to delay everything a
year and stay here in portland and just
to take one
one class right
and obviously i was really upset about
it my parents were too
and subhanallah bro i spent three weeks
non-stop just trying to look for
solutions and one door would open and
i'd be really excited about it and then
couple days later it would close and
another door to open it would close and
it just kept happening subhanallah this
was during ramadan too
and i just at the back of my head this
is where i really learned to because i'm
like yeah allah you know that i'm doing
everything that i can i'm trying my
hardest to find a solution
and all these all these opportunities
that i think are like they just keep not
working out but yeah allah i know that
you know like you have what's best
planned for me and subhanallah bro the
last thing like a week before school
ended
like the
you know just another door randomly
opened and i was in and out and it
worked out in like the matter of a week
and i got it figured out and i'm still
able to take my gap year and everything
and it was a lot it was a lot cheaper
than
the alternative options that i thought
were like great so subhanallah bro you
really put your trust in allah and and
he'll take care of you man
i was beautiful
i was beautiful man so what was the was
the question again
you threw me off bro when you when you
chimed in with that it was beautiful i
went live but the question was uh
[Music]
when do you know you're ready for
marriage yeah how do you know
uh okay so
my answer is that
you don't know
you don't know if you're ready
but it's like i said
and i was on you know agreeing with you
on your statement
that has to be that mental place like
you you have to mentally
have some kind of idea
that you're like okay i can i can
someone do this
you don't know that you're ready but you
have like mentally this idea of like
okay you know what this this can
actually work
and then of course like it all connects
with
what fired and romney was saying like
you you have to be able to be selfless
that's when you know i'd say
oh i mean i'm kind of going against
myself here but
if you're in a selfless state i feel
like you you're like you're pretty much
there like you you can handle a marriage
uh but the next thing that i want to say
is when you were talking about the
the list
writing down the traits
of like what you're looking for in the
spouse
um
i think that's very powerful
but
not in the way that people think
it is
right
people think that they write down this
list and that allah is going to provide
them this exact person listen allah may
well i may not provide you this exact
person but i think it's very important
to write this list out because when you
write this list out
you actually see for yourself what it is
that you're looking for and then once
you're done writing that list out you
throw it away because at the end of the
day like allah is the one that's going
to provide for you not yourself you're
not going to go out here and find this
perfect woman that matches this
description that you wrote down out of
the millions billions of women in this
world
come on now like it's not going to
happen it's all it's all a lot that's
gonna make it happen so once once you
write that down you know you you have
an idea you you now know exactly what
you want so that when allah puts it in
front of you
you can make that connection you can see
it for what it is
and i think it's very very important
to pray this the harder
yeah yeah very beautifully said
mashaallah i don't want to cut you off
you're done but i don't want to lose my
train i thought
go ahead
so i have i think three more points i
want to share
um related to what angel said
i'm already forgetting it man
we're gonna rename our podcast from the
three muslims to the three rude boys bro
because we keep cutting one another off
bro today what's going on
we're all just uh very excited to uh
talk about this topic here we go i uh
okay yeah so
you might find
after you get married things about your
spouse that you love that you never knew
you would love
so writing a list beforehand and all
that stuff i was on jose's like might
not be that beneficial because you're
going to get married and find there are
things about your spouse you've never
really thought about that you love that
they do right and if you were to get
remarried and your new spouse isn't like
that
there might be a little bit of a gap so
there's a lot to consider and as angel
ended up with istahara is so important
because allah knows every single factor
of you that their situation your
situation your families your friends
your life your experience everything
and you barely remember you know
majority of the stuff yourself or can
consider
those things in your own life yourself
the second
advice i want to give is in islam you
know allah and the prophet said they
talk about marriage allah says
he put between a man and a woman
passionate love and mercy
right
passionate loving
so people have the passion to love part
down nowadays but do they have the mercy
part not really so we have to go back to
islam and see what islam says about
marriage and study it literally study it
what it means the rights and so on and
so forth that's the second piece the
last piece of advice
i want to give for people nowadays
because it didn't happen it wasn't too
much of an issue in the past but
nowadays it's an issue because people
don't know what a man is what a woman is
they don't know if they're a man or a
woman so there's a lot of issues with
that um but the advice i want to give is
for men to understand women and know
that they're not like a man they don't
think like a man they don't act like a
man the things that they say
in a situation nine times out of ten is
not what a man would say in that same
situation it's not because one's worse
they're just not the same and same thing
with women understand that your man is
is is not like a woman if there's a more
efficient way to do something and you're
sitting there looking over your man like
fix a sink and you're telling him do
this do that he's not going to like that
even if his way is more difficult it's
his way and he wants to do it his way if
you let him do it his way struggle and
get it done that would be so much better
than if you're sitting there pestering
him and saying no do this do that men
don't like that stuff so understand how
opposite gender works please it's so
important for marriage
and like bro so many so many women are
going to hear this be like y'all
misogynist you know no it's not
misogynistic to say so because this is
based on quran bro there's a hadith
about i believe there's a hadith about
women being like a like a bad rip bro if
you try to straighten it you know try to
be just like a man try to straighten
it's going to crack off
you know
so it's better you just leave it as it
is you know and appreciate it
i'm gonna just say real quick i feel
like
people more and more nowadays are
starting to realize the lie that like
society has just pushed on
us that this third world femme of men
and women
are the same
can you guys look at me i'm cutting out
yeah
i'll give you a bit like
there we go
okay um
this
idea that like men and women are the
same and we have to treat them the same
men and women are equal
there's a very big difference between
being equal and being the same
biologically we're not the same right
mentally emotionally
we are built different and you have to
acknowledge that because
what like
the people that suffer the most from
this whole third wave of feminism and
this idea of men have to be equal to
women are actually the women because
that you know doing what's most
honorable which is raising a family
raising kids having actual feminine
qualities they're told you have to
compete with men your priority is your
career it's not your kids it's your
career you know and this is it causes it
there's a
big imbalance in society that i feel
like we're seeing nowadays where
first of all people aren't even getting
it right but people do get married
divorce right now is like 55 60 percent
like the
and so all these imbalances are
happening and
i feel like if if if men played the role
that they're supposed to play and women
played the role that supposed to play
a lot of these issues
you wouldn't find
yeah
100
no that's [ __ ]
i don't know why why the thing got so
choppy bro but we just
couldn't sleep
your audio just your video
yeah
and i agree feel good though
brother
104 people here join the chat and become
a member for night in a month bro that's
damn near free bro subhanallah and and
i'm shall i get a reward
that uh we're getting if not more bro
just for supporting us and facilitating
us in sha allah subscribe
now bro but
to add my point before i forget because
i'm notorious for forgetting bro
i'm already forgetting as i'm like
[Music]
i was i was
i was gonna say about moaz bro
it's always the ones that that don't
want to get married right now that loki
want to get married the most bro
yeah right ain't that are you muted bro
listen bro i'm a guy at the end of the
day of course i want to get married
qualifications for wife number one
i feel like because again we would
always talk about this with the guys and
i'd always be like like yeah like i
could get married young but at the same
time like like
imagine all like the things i could
accomplish if i'm just like grinding it
out on my own and this and that and blah
blah blah and like
you know like it should be harder when
you're married and whatnot right and one
of my friends was like listen
first of all
like
he said it beautifully subhanallah he
said
how do you not know that allah will put
barakah in those goals that you have
because you decide
to be responsible to be a man and to get
married right
like
from you taking something on like that
for the sake of allah you know
he could actually put barakah in those
goals that you think you can't do you
know while you're married
so subhanallah it's like a perspective
shift and again if i'm being honest part
of it honestly is the responsibility and
the commitment like i understand it's a
huge commitment and i don't know if i'm
ready to commit to that just yet so i'll
be honest there's there's that aspect of
like
am i am i really a man yet i know how
important that is i'm not there yet
so yeah so
there's this um this is completely aside
from what i want to say you're making me
forget even more about saying this bro
but um yeah go ahead sorry
no you're good bro you're good i'm just
playing i was i was gonna wait till
after the plot to tell you guys but i'm
gonna just say it now what i do with
podcast is when a thought comes in my
head i'll write it down i have a piece
of paper in front of me i'll write it
down so i don't forget it might help i
should do that
i should do that next time yeah
we should do that but we'll be always
muslim [ __ ] this guy you don't see anal
have a stack of papers bro just writing
stuff down
little post-its
there we go
but um if i was muslim and i was reading
the bible
there's this one thing where it says
like
uh
don't
gain the world
don't lose your soul just or don't gain
the world and then lose your soul in the
process
so it's like if you can just
bring that into this situation you're
talking about like having vodka and what
you're doing achieving all this stuff
and it's like this is all cool
but this is
all part of the dunya that you just said
and it's like yeah even getting married
is still part of dunya but
getting married is
completing half your deen and
should
bring you closer to allah and the whole
goal is to get closer to allah so
it's like it's like the saying that
perhaps you get married and that will
put the barakah
in what it is that you're doing maybe
before what it is that you were doing
there actually was no barakah in it but
to you you were thinking there was
barakah
but in reality
allah didn't see it that big you saw it
as a big deal allah didn't see it that
big then you saw marriage is not a big
deal but allah saw it as a big deal
so it's just something to take into
consideration and before before anyone
chimes in
i really
really should say what i was going to
say previously or this is going to be
gone forever bro
all right now i was talking about the
list
and i was talking about istahada
right
when you pray this sahara
you ask allah
like if this is good for me
in this life in the next in my deen my
religion
then make it easy for me right and then
what i do is i ask allah for a sign
and i ask a lot to make it clear to me i
don't want to i don't want to be
guessing and trying to think like oh is
this a sign or not i want a lot to make
it clear to me now when you write this
list let's say as you're writing this
list something comes up as like oh
you know i never thought about this but
i actually want
my significant other to choose me
not just be with me but choose me you
never thought about that
wallet you never thought about that but
you just thought about it you think
that's a coincidence
it's not
and you might think it's insignificant
you might think oh it's like okay i'm
just writing this down it's really not a
big of a deal no one's ever gonna see
this um you throw it away but you know
what you just
literally made yourself aware of
something that you were unaware of now
when you pray that's the other and allah
sends you that sign
it may have been that that one thing
that you became aware of when you were
writing that list
will not be the one thing
that will allow you to become aware of
the sign that allah sends you
and i wanted to touch on the point that
both of y'all mentioned but you know
what mars was saying that you know like
i want to get to a point where you know
i'm like accelerated right now you know
i can i can do all my goals solo and
then worry about marriage but bro
why would you not want to want to have
you know your meals ready
your laundry folded you know every
aspect of your life taken care of if she
really is now for you and takes care of
you and and is on the same team and on
the same page and wants to help you for
your goals and you can actually focus on
the things that you do
you know and i'm not listen i'm not
going to give a fake answer bro i'm not
going to this is not like a shouting
answer or anything like that because i
know anytime we speak about this like oh
you know women don't belong in the
kitchen or the other thing is women
belong in the kitchen you know there's
two parties to everything but i'm just
speaking from a personal point of view
you know in terms of how much i
appreciate my wife and just having
everything taken care of in the
household even with my business but just
helping me with all the all the
background stuff
it just really helps me double down and
focus on what i do and that's something
that i couldn't do before because i
would have to be in charge of doing all
these things it's kind of like
having someone that's like there for
supporting you and it frees up and
allocates a lot of more room for you to
do what you got to do you know hope that
makes sense
i actually never thought of that
perspective at all subhanallah
yeah one more thing i want to add on to
that quickly is that um
having honestly had being married and
i'm not married yet right i have a
fiance but even just have you know being
engaged is something that is so
motivating as a man you find a lot of
men the dow carries
they say that their wife is their
backbone and obviously as a single man
we don't understand what that means
until we get married if you have a good
righteous pious wife
she will be like a backbone too she will
be like
this this um
you know people don't associate strength
with women a lot of the time but for
i i honestly believe for a lot of men
their women is
you know would be their strength in the
back end just something that keeps them
going motivates them and makes them feel
like a man honestly especially when
you're working like out in the field
working towards you know providing for
your wife when you have that kind of
responsibility like we were talking
about before
even that
motivates a man and gives him strength
and i think that's something else that's
really important to remember if you want
to achieve your goals get married
because it'll push you to achieve your
force
bro it was even narrated by the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam so
one of the best things that we can do or
one of the best things in this dunya
is a pious wife
yeah the best of temporary enjoyment and
stuff yeah
guys i have to hop off here i have work
so i gotta get going but this has been
amazing you guys you know keep continue
keep going insha'allah and may allah
bless you all endlessly i'm gonna head
off
marriage in the thumbnail now
i already changed the title bro
yeah but every single time we do a
podcast bro and it's it's kind of
wrapping up we do a little bit of a q a
right now so inshallah we'll do that if
any of the viewers have any questions
um for you you know inshallah they
definitely do so
if y'all got any questions for brother
moaz to answer you know at the
discretion of himself if he wants to
answer it or not even because we're
going to leave it up to him
no pressure uh leave the comments right
now in the live chat insha allah and
we're going to wrap this up in about 10
minutes
but
to to kind of spin off that point bro i
wanted to i want to say how much like
you know women today in in society
they're so conflicted bro especially
muslim women and sisters like they're
conflicted between okay here's what my
parents want from me here's what society
wants from me here's what my friends
want from me here's what i'm seeing on
netflix and tv and i know like okay yeah
men watch netflix and tv too but women
are are more emotional and hardwired to
be more emotionally susceptible and
influenced by nature so when they see
these things about you know rom comes
and and it's you know romance novels and
this
they can't help sometimes but to set
these unrealistic expectations of like
okay this is how like marriage is
supposed to be this is how like love is
supposed to be this is how romance is
supposed to be you know and men too
because men are watching you know haram
on the internet you know one time a day
they're not practicing nofap and they
have this unrealistic expectation of how
a woman is supposed to be too right so
it goes both ways the reality is until
you have that hard you know skin in the
game experience where it's like okay i'm
married now you can't really understand
you know the vicissitudes about marriage
and the logistics and that's why it's
very hard to you know answer the
question that you ask
it's it's it's not a black and white
thing
it's it's seldom something that you can
you know read about it's like basketball
you know you can you can read about you
know free throws and and
layups and everything bro
until you get hooping on the court yeah
it's different it's very lit it's like
it's like you can't do much with a
parked car and just studying about
driving all this until you photo on the
gas and you know and i'm not saying to
be impulsive but there's some things in
life that the best lesson is experience
now i love that analogy you that's
that's 100 right
yeah
and
that like the thing with with
unrealistic expectations too i feel like
social media has to play such like not
just social media like you said just the
movies and everything in general i feel
like that was a big kind of red flag for
me when i when i started tick tock and
everything because i started
realizing i do a lot of like reflecting
and whatnot and so i started realizing
that my whole perspective
of of a lot of things in the dean are
starting to change because of the
content i'm consuming on tick tock
especially marriage because it's talked
about in such a way bro that like if no
one were to like if someone were to hop
on tick tock for the first time and
start seeing these things they'd be like
what the heck like what's what's going
on here you know it's so
twisted and swayed but it's like
it's sneaky where it's like you can't
just be like bro that's haram what the
heck you feel me
and so like
you have to take a step back from that
and
and and
kind of just gauge it in the real world
and even like you see all these like
muslim couples and whatnot that
but look i'm gonna be totally honest
i absolutely hate it when people post
that kind of stuff not because like oh
i'm jealous and i want that but i'm like
bro the amount of first of all the
amount of asset you're asking for and
the amount of evil you're asking for
number one but two you are you are part
of the problem of causing this
unrealistic expectation of marriage
because all you're doing is posting
these happy pictures of
walks on the beach and all this kind of
stuff and you brought me followers for
valentine's day
bro you're you're corrupting these minds
of these people that are like if that's
not me every day then i don't want it
with my husband or i don't want it with
my wife it's such a big problem bro
and so that's kind of like that's one
one big thing that i kind of have with
social media and i feel like you really
have to gauge it
and and understand the dangers of it you
know that's a big thing i'm not i'm not
advocating anymore i used to advocate
for like you need to like delete
instagram completely disconnect bro
again like we talked about earlier you
have to do with the environment that
let's put you in social media isn't
going to go away the internet isn't
going to go away right you have to
realize that but then
be very aware of the dangers that it can
cause to
you know and then proceed and see if you
still want to use it if you want to
limit it whatever bro you know they
literally do studies on how social media
like we can rewire your brain like
rewire the neural pathways in your brain
they've done studies on this kind of
stuff and you see nowadays bro like the
increased level of adhd of depression of
anxiety bro like kids nowadays and even
my generation and like you know younger
younger our siblings generation
we have a very very hard time focusing
on one thing for a lengthened amount of
time
because
what these apps like tik tok and
instagram have done is that they've
they've it's like a slot machine we know
this right you go from from one piece of
content to a completely different
subject and you just your brain keeps
switching topics and topics and you
can't focus on one thing that is a huge
problem bro because in the real world
you would need in order to do productive
work you have to be able to focus on one
thing for a long amount of time
you know and so it's these small things
that are starting we're now starting to
realize this but you need to kind of
really find solutions for it in yourself
first you know and then society as a
whole or else like the dangers can be
really really detrimental
that's deep bro never thought of it like
that
brother ali writes one bit of advice for
guys looking for a wife if she says she
doesn't want to cook drop her that's
facts that's the thing see it's not a
woman's only job to be in the kitchen
but if she's against wanting to cook for
you there's there's no reason she should
be wanting to be against that right
subhanallah
uh we got another question uh super chat
any key takeaway from college that would
benefit
let us know
shameless plug i'm about to post the
youtube video about the biggest lessons
i learned from uni so stay tuned for
that but
the one thing i will say the um
the one thing i will say subhanallah is
enjoy the journey man you guys have
heard that quote where it's like the
person who enjoys walking will travel
farther than the person who enjoys the
destination something along those lines
right
like as as much as it sucks to
like studying isn't fun all this kind of
stuff right but again it's it's about
perspective bro like take a step back
and like when you're in a lab or when
you're like
you know study groups with your friends
in the library late at night should be
like yo like
i'm never gonna get to do this again
like when i graduate
this isn't you know it's gonna be a one
and done i'm gonna work i'm gonna have a
family i'm not gonna get to experience
this again the late nights with friends
the um
you know just going out like
i understand bro again i understand like
college wasn't fun for me it was i
didn't i don't enjoy studying but then
subhanallah graduation bro i was looking
back and and part of me missed it and i
i never thought i was going to say that
but like part of me actually misses that
experience because i never really
actually took time to experience it my
whole mindset was all right get this
done as soon as possible graduate early
you know so you can just move on with
your life but bro you have to
learn to enjoy every single phase of
your life because you're never going to
get that phase back
right
so that that's that's that's my one
thing i'll mention for now no that's
facts bro that's one thing my mother
always stressed to me she said you know
that whole thing about you know when
when it's all said and done that that's
a chapter of your life you're never
going to go back
bro by by time verily man is in a state
of lust it's
allah doesn't write the believer or the
disbeliever you know
both
mankind is in a state of laws there's no
no one can turn back the clock you know
that's that's one that's a tough pill to
swallow subhanallah when arnold flies to
canada in two weeks and we set up the
in-person podcast we might even make a
whole episode like on the podcast just
about time management because it's such
an important thing today that a lot of
people are just taking for granted bro
whether janae writes these companies how
to psychologists when they make those
apps to see how to keep a person on the
app for long periods of time stuff scary
it's deep bro it's deep see when i would
think of some like some like you know a
nerd in like some cubicle you know
trying to like you know worry about how
to like perfectly make these apps and
like what goes into it it's really easy
to do like a dopamine detox or like
social media clients you know
but speaking of dopamine detox on health
bro
what advice do you have for people that
are hooked into social media now that
we're talking about
it before before i say anything on that
i was still thinking about what the
brother he had said
over the people posting the pictures of
like the marriage and stuff like that
like bro just ask yourself this question
man like do you really want all these
other men to look at your woman
and bro like let's be honest man let's
be honest we can be
we can be as like religious as possible
we can really strive to be as close to
allah as possible
but allah made us weak
to women
and we could be married and we're still
like that's still a weakness where we
have to lower our gaze and like you have
all these guys that on the internet who
you know when like you're surfing you
know you're mindlessly scrolling
it's hard to lower your gaze if you're
mindlessly scrolling you're not fully
there there's like this lag time period
so like they might see that and they
might look just a little bit too long
and
bro god god knows best allah knows best
what's going on in their head
when they see
this dude's wife and stuck for a lot
like let's
let's not be part of that let's not even
support it or anything like that man for
real
savannah bro you you read this question
without even reading it bro what's
y'all's opinion about men nowadays
showing the wives on social media
it became so normalized yeah i guess
that's it allah mentions that the youth
will never enter jannah bro this is like
we're not just saying you know pulling
things out of thin air it is deep and
it's it's things where it's like when
you're too plugged into society and the
matrix you think it's like okay it's
insecure if you're you know you're not
okay with you know showing off your wife
for all this they use these shaming
tactics you know the reality is all men
are born with fitra and they have credit
bro we have this innate sense of
protective jealousy and we really don't
want that bro
yeah
real quick back to the point of social
media have either of you guys seen the
social dilemma on netflix not yet bro
bro you guys need to get on that right
now and everyone that's watching the
social dilemma on netflix
it
basically it's like a documentary but
they bring like people who originally
created like these apps like instagram
and twitter and whatnot and they
basically kind of exposed these secrets
about how these apps were built bro it's
it's the it's the most eye-opening thing
i've seen about how social media works
social dilemma bro everyone go watch
that for sure
inshallah
okay let's see
we got we got something from nafisa what
to do if you fail for the man
you realize to ask that question damn
100 damn
i'll follow him on uh oh for the man
insta for inspirational videos bro what
currency is that
i think there's rupees
i feel like if we convert that it's
gonna be like two dollars and fifty
cents um
i don't know bro
here though exactly bro it's not about
the money but i've never seen that
currency in my life yeah i don't know
what the question was to be honest is it
an insult she's saying that she would
when she was saying that she was into
the brother
i mean he's a handsome brother but if i
was a woman i'd be into him too much
we could get through this without
without embarrassing me but
he about to write i love moz when he
talks about girls not learning basic
stuff from motherhood and femininity but
just chasing careers this is not helping
families at all kids being abandoned at
daycare
centers bro this listen all the topics
we're talking about is is our link today
you know you women not focusing on this
your kids are going to be raised by the
internet so social media all of this you
know
and the internet is not going to teach
them what they need to know pornography
for a man is not going to teach him you
know about real intimacy to all the
fathers that are kind of you know
dragging their feet about having to talk
with his son
yeah
100
nah bro i really think that's like
either yen or rupees
rupees that's
i just saw 100 i was like oh my god
i need bro
listen i opened the chat publicly i need
someone to like find what this currency
is and just paste it down in the in the
description box i really think it's a
ruby's role it's the currency
i i think it is man rupees would say inr
indian rupees
you know
i don't know so we need someone for that
but anyway guys if y'all don't have any
other questions we're going to wrap this
up in sha allah
uh summarize that's what they use on
cayman islands bro he fancy
really
i think that's cap bro i think they're
pulling a leg
yes we'll never know bro stay tuned
until next time where we find out what
currency that is insha allah and uh
brother moaz bro any questions that you
have for us
for you guys
how actually i do
you guys kind of
you guys also already mentioned it i
forgot which podcast it was but how have
y'all stayed so consistent with like the
podcast and everything because i feel
like that's one thing like i really look
up to you guys where you've been able to
grow this channel so much and i feel
like like it has to be hard managing
three people's schedule as well and you
guys all have busy lives how have you
guys been able to manage that
bro
i gotta give credit where credit is due
and that is to fayette because he's the
one that's been
uh coordinating all that
but honestly man in terms of like the
consistency
i think there's um
[Music]
i think there's power in numbers
because bro like
with myself i have to force myself to to
be consistent for my own youtube channel
but with the podcast with the brothers
here like
there's no force like it just happens
you know
and um i'm sure they can speak for
themselves as well
it's the same thing
now bro you're right because
see and allah will just have qualifier
for that but
i wanted to say that most of the
ventures that i've tried in my life one
it's not fisable and it's not for the
sake of allah when there's no
way doing something for the approval and
validation and love
of allah
it's always going to look like an uphill
battle bro i've seen people that try to
start a business bro i've seen people
try to make youtube they've been doing
youtube for 10 15 years they still got
2k subs now i'm not trying to you know
hate on them and throw any dirt on them
you know keep trying keep hustling but
at the end of the day you're going to
know if something's meant for you and
you're going to know something's not
meant for you and one thing about
youtube is from the jump ah nia was
never about dunya material gains nothing
though the way we started this podcast
i'm sure you probably heard this in
another another episode or so
but this one time
me angel and rami right the three of us
we were speaking to one of our friends
okay this is a non-muslim brother right
it was around the time that i was
getting on deen
just reverted masha'allah and
it's kind of natural
for the fourth person to kind of be like
you know i'm kind of interested in this
tune though you know no peer pressure
because we we didn't want to give him
doubt but he was he was interested he
came to me he's like you know can i can
i read about can i you know should i
read the quran what should i do you know
is there any of the resources you
recommend and what me rami and uncle
started doing was we started having
these talks with them i don't think we
had that many
but what i know for damn sure is at the
end of the first talk
when the brother left the chat and it
was just us three
we just stopped and and wondered like
there was so much value that we
ourselves got from this talk even though
we weren't giving dawa to ourselves
right but just reinforcing and just like
going over things and just reviewing you
know different concepts and it was just
so much of an even boost at the very
least bare minimum
that had we just hit record and even one
more soul
would have tuned in and just heard the
conversation
there would have been so much value in
so much baraka karagan insha allah so we
realized we're going to continue having
these talks that we have anyway right
it's not like it's like a time
commitment or a financial commitment or
anything we're doing these talks anyway
why not just hit the record button and
just post it on the internet and have a
webcam too while we're at it what
difference does it make we're still
going to continue doing what we're doing
but now we're letting other people in
on the blessings and the value and
everything that they could get in sha
allah that's essentially why we started
and and if we renew our intention
regularly which it's you know this is a
reminder to ourselves too we're not
perfect
and we keep that intention you know
fresh and renewed that we just want one
person
to just come back to islam and come
deeper into islam that was near from the
get-go
allah just over-delivers bro that's
that's the truth
i love that that's a beautiful way to
start
it's finally
100 bro
let's see honestly guys i can't wait
till they're in their own studio
together increasing i mean
i mean it's been long overdue guys for
anyone that made it this far a loyal t3m
family member
we are starting our in-person podcast
studio very soon
first legit in-person episode drops july
1st you know
save that on your calendar insha allah
and brother moaz is going to be back in
sha allah bro if you ever canada
come through to the podcast in person
we'd love to host you as a guest
what uh what province are you guys in
we're in ontario bro
oh
okay we're in ontario but if you're
driving up here from the states exact
it's actually going to be in the first
city that you hit up which is niagara
falls in ontario
i might have to make a quick pay stop
then inshallah allah insha allah bro
okay last comment we got from sister
wyatt discipline is key do something
because you have to even if you don't
want to that's really how one grows and
succeeds that's what it is bro
you know at the end of the day
it's not an excuse to say oh i don't
want to praise allah so i'm not going to
pray until i feel like you know oh i
don't want to fast today
see the thing with the thing with being
a real man is doing what you're supposed
to do
even if you don't feel like it most of
the time you're not gonna feel like it
you know so at the end of the day that's
what separates people that are emotional
you know and they rely on emotions and
feelings which are transient right and
fleeting
and those that know okay i have to do it
because you know at the end of the day
if i can't stand by my word what else do
i have
100 what are the practices i said say he
said the one who the one amongst you who
is actually strong isn't the one who's
able to physically overcome the other
one it's the one who's able to control
his anger at a time of at a time of
radha at a time of anger so it's the
understanding as a man bro
it's not about how much money you get or
how many girls you can pull or any of
that kind of stuff that's what society
tells you bro a real man is is is a
master of himself
his his his shadowed his his his own
desires have no control over him at all
that's the definition of a real man
and i think that's the point we're going
to end it on inshallah
smash that like button links in the
description for brother mother's youtube
channel make sure you go there and
subscribe show him some love inshallah
today he's going to drop a video very
soon
um but more as anything else
has been an absolute
honors all mine thank you guys so much
for inviting me i i wish we could go
longer but inshaallah we'll have more
talks in the future
may allah bless you
immensely and and give you a lot of
value
and knowledge and wisdom and everything
in this one year that you're about to
study
and once you return to academia at least
secular academia with uh with dentistry
may love bless you for that
make it four years i think it's four
years because years four years make it
four years for you to remember bro that
shapes you and inshallah if this is
world for you to have as a career choice
to facilitate that give you ease give
your blessing in that i mean
i
appreciate it all
and all right bro you want to do the
closing door
um